m
le conseil départemental et la région
réunion organisée la fête de l'aïd el
fitr à la villa du département
un moment de fête de partage mais aussi
une rencontre amicale et chaleureuse
après le mois sacré de ramadan
je sais
moi
et
ça le ramadan c'est le neuvième mois du
calendrier lunaire
ça représente un moment très fort où le
croyant refait un peu le point sur sa
vie sur le sens de sa vie seule
orientation qu'il donne pour l'année à
venir selon moi également de faire le
bilan de ses actions
c'est un peu une inspection intérieur de
tout son être intérieur et le sens de la
vie c'est une période assez importante
et un des piliers de l'islam donc c'est
une période de jeunes non seulement
s'abstenir de manger boire mais aussi
faire des bonnes actions en fait puisque
le but c'est de s'améliorer pas juste de
ne pas manger voir mais faire du bien
être généreux aider les uns les autres
s'abstenir c'est fini tu allemands aussi
on veut éviter les mauvaises langues et
ladi lafé mais vraiment devenir meilleur
partage et aussi aider les gens qui sont
dans le besoin
fête de l'eid c'est la fête de la joie
et dans toutes les religions
la joie est précédé par un temps de
prier un temps d'ascèse donc pour nos
amis musulmans le ramadan et ça ne vous
invite tous à dire c'est un moment mais
dans la vie de tous les jours ce doit
être connais ça parce que
il ne faut davantage de sobriété
davantage de temps au silence davantage
de temps à la prière et à la rencontre
alors joyeux et idole de noah mills à
cette réception était convié la
communauté musulmane mais aussi des
réunionnais de toutes confessions
confondues la diversité du peuple
réunionnais et sa capacité à vivre
ensemble et sans doute la plus grande
richesse du dealer nous on est dans un
dans une religion dont on est tous ces
mélanges et aussi bien aimé continuer
comme ça si sur ce petit petit bout de
terre dans l'océan indien
toutes les communautés toutes les
religions ont réussi à organiser une vie
commune en donnant un sens au mot
fraternité égalité et je pense qu'à
partir de là cette expérience peut âtre
peut-être pas un exemple mais une
indication qu'on peut vivre ensemble
tout le monde quelle que soit son
origine
et quelle que soit sa religion et ça
c'est le plus important
surtout par les temps qui courent je
sais pas si on peut dire que la réunion
représente un exemple mais c'est un vécu
originale qui est intéressant parce que
nous sommes à la fois le produit de
l'histoire
et puis là avec le développement de la
fraternité sur un métissage en
transversalité de nombreuses activités
étaient au programme de cette journée
festive
eni tressage de fait que comme musique
ou encore concours culinaire ont fait de
cette réception un moment convivial
marek malik ordre